vous posez des questions igor et grichka
tous les chroniqueurs wam m et lisa ou
vous répondez avec franchement way ou
bien ont mangé pendant n'importe quoi
sous la cloche c'est forcément
dégueulasse obsa banon s'est pas
forcément légal je peux avoir des trucs
dont et rassurez vous les choses khadra
cloche ils sont encore puisque je vous
rappelle que kelly mais novelli est en
vacances à notre voie là tout va bien
dans le meilleur des mondes
je sais pas pourquoi mais j'aimerais
bien prendre ta cloche et te donner la
mienne témoin serait bien celle d'élise
avant qu'on arrive pas je me dis qu'il
adore tous ici sur menthon assistant il
a dit 'je il croit vraiment et en
informant que la production a peur de
moi exact qui ce sont dix ans peur
d'être viré à la fin de la saison et tu
t'en donner un truc où la cloche vous
les trouverez toute une filature
bachelot oui parce que c'est pas bête
comme raisonnement
si tu veux on échangera quand ça sera
ton tour très bien le dire à tous vas tu
y tiens j'y crois que c'est une question
grichka grichka à non mais non je vais
poser une question à d'abord à benjamin
oms et d'autres femmes aurore on sait
que votre femme au rang mais très
jalouse avec quel chroniqueuse de tpm
paix voudriez vous passez une nuit un
truc dégueulasse et tu dis bonjour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi très bons termes et vous
comment ça vient tous ce que vous sortez
comme ça de front on va excusez-moi
dissipation et suce ma roue c'était moi
vous suivez un petit peu l'émission mère
fatma et sans rigoler ont duré un mec à
roland garros qui te font rien un mec
comme ça
roland garros confrères non et combien
de ces communs et là c'est nadal qui
joue l'atout thèmes sérieux mais
pourquoi il a dit ça avec moi qui sera
pas jalouse forcément merci alors là
vous avez trop vite pour nous moi j'ai
compris on veut juste la vérité oui bon
on va juste la vérité ou la vérité où tu
manges nom serait pas sa part mais
autrement dit non castaldi je te jure
n'en fais très attention à toi combat
c'est en haute egypte est je suis comme
ça des gens qui croient en castaldi
personnes non non je vous dirais
m'arrêter je voudrais m'arrêter
ben avec lui avec le divine at il dit
viseraient tout
[Musique]
caroline ithurbide aussi de la
heureusement c'est bon c'est bon vous
êtes sauvés allez on est une question
maintenant pour valérie et a6 une
météorite tombe sur le plateau vous
pouvez sauver tous les chroniqueurs sauf
un quel est le nom de celui que vous
laisser périr pouvait dire matthieu
delormeau vous mangez vous désignez
alors vous pouvez manger sinon web alors
je mange parce que je mangeais
nécessaire d un magnifique oignons et
plus allez-y benali et ce soir c'est
fatal s'il va être content j'ai quand
même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez les médailles
ok et croquer bien fixe avallon abdallah
alesi encore encore comment ça qui fait
dit dit et maintenant vous allez vous
tourner vers à jean-michel j'ai croqué
dans le choc dont le nom shi j'ai croqué
[Rires]
voilà
gerbaud chafic attention attention
danger l'écho y est tu passe toujours
pour le gentil mais quel est le
chroniqueur que tu aimes le moins autour
de la table sinon tu manges
ouais ouais chroniqueur que tu aimes le
moins sinon tu manges où tu donnes la
réponse que tu manges série mais tu sais
que ja je viens de plus un peu le truc à
faire je tiens au hasard mais non pas au
hasard tu dis vraiment ça me tahou la
vérité on sait très bien maintenant
matthieu delormeau comme un cri du coeur
regarde ce qu'il y avait avant j'ai pour
toi regardera dit regardez prend le 20
10 ou 20
c'est pas c'est quoi à des gens qui ont
des sables délicieux c'est là pourquoi
j'ai regardé veulent manger comme ça je
connais jean louis schlesser évoqueront
le prince terrain chronicle
alors alors attention jean michel vous
inquiétez pas la question est très
simple
oki laval on ne me l'avait pas vous il
faut pas bouder la m
bon alors je vais poser une question
hammami la mairie isabelle chéri si vous
deviez choisir entre garder votre boulot
à tpm paix à rtl
where they à quel serait votre choix ou
bien vous mangez veut manger
alors regardez le regard c'est très bon
c'est un cheese couilles c'est ta mère
je vous dise et astuces mais non pas du
tout invensys à nous il c'est à dire
c'est comme un petit sketch avec du
fenouil alors voulait pas dire qu'elle a
le droit à la droite jimmy jimmy jimmy
il vient de lui qui vient de venir sont
scorpio un jimmy à ma mère j'avais dit
messieurs open jimmy jimmy question si
bas possible mais vous êtes obligé de
répondre puisque c'est le ramadan est
donc serré merci comme ça c'est clair
donc là
10 me mohamed ma question est simple dit
me si vous étiez si vous étiez moi tu
veux arrêter avec ce scorpion obrou jeu
il bouge ne sort pas la menace est
presque aussi bon qui bouge c'est si
vous voyez quelque chose bouger à côté
de jean-michel c'est pas le scorpion
aller sur jimmy si vous étiez si vous
étiez mois quelques chroniqueurs
présents ce soir ne serait pas autour de
la table l'année prochaine voilà c'est
bien pour la cohésion du groupe
[Rires]
je veux dire la vérité serait francesca
st pas expliqué pourquoi il ya ce que
vous allez trouver vêtements alors c'est
un point de vue personnel
bien sûr que je suis pas là pour faire
semblant mais je la trouvais beaucoup
plus performante et qui est beaucoup
plus sa place dans ces que de la télé je
trouve que le personnage et marché
nettement mieux
après c'est que mon ami de
téléspectateurs oui tu as raison mais
après ces deux semaines je n'aime pas se
dire qu'elle est calibré hier dans les
deux mails encore meilleur dans ses
colères qui fait vraiment très paris en
plus elle coûte moins cher là-bas
jean michel maire à la question pour
vous attention jean michel jean michel
maire ou vous répondez où vous mangez
jean-michel
je lis ou la question de jean michel
martelly et caroline ithurbide tu
choisis qui pour la vie qui pour la nuit
qui est une choisit pas voilà alors sur
une nuit je prendrais carline turbide
bon la vanille francesca tim kelly déjà
elle n'a pas besoin de moi
la galerie de moyens de mieux que moi
que les autres ouais ça a été le cas dit
ya quelques années maintenant vous les
connaissez bien classés les chroniqueurs
de la table de plus intelligent moins
intelligent vous mangez bien mangez vous
et moi j'ai alors réfléchi manger alors
je vous dire ce qu'il en est à attendre
a déclaré fléchi vous mangez mais je
mange je suis incapable de sur lionel
mathis a sur la tête vers 1 on dirait
qu'on était à la question 1 millions $
et maury j'appelle la même image et bien
vous allez manger
nous ce qu'on appelle pitié du guacamole
c'est une tartine de quoi kaboul c'est
magnifique tartine avec du bois kamal
avec des moules vous aimez les moules
oui c'est bon la lourdeur
lourdeur des sanctions lourdes jusqu'à
grichka bogdanoff qu'à ses yeux la
question pour vous attention où vous
mangez vous répondez grichka avez vous
déjà eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique sur un ton visage
bon ben je réponds très facilement vous
avez dit nord déjà mais oui je maintiens
non mais non je vous dis pas ce qu'ils
ont fait des expériences sert au pardon
mes expérimentations suite mais
l'expérience a commenté pète chimie ils
ont pris un bec bunsen frères des tubes
du ghana plus spécialement et s'adonner
à ça mais c'est très bon non mais c'est
vrai comment non mais parce que voilà
comme ça au moins c'est clair
alors posez plus d'émissions c'est clair
voilà donc tu as répondu et en fait j'ai
fait des expérimentations
c'est à dire c'est alors vas-y des
maires de twilight alors non mais il est
très bon il trouvera toute façon une
manière fictive de l'expérimentation
quoi pas du tout en réalité ce qui nous
est ce qui nous a été imposée il ya
longtemps nous étions c'est la vérité la
vérité aussi à s'assurer qu'ils soient
unis et les gens trouvaient qu'on se
retrouve et on se ressemblaient beaucoup
mais même trop alors tu sais que là bas
on se demandait tous les ans on était en
face de gens qui nous demandent est
invariablement mais je sais pas du tout
lequel ressemble le plus à l'autre par
exemple une des questions
d'accord alors oui et donc alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé ça m'arrange pas
frères pouvaient parler français parce
que la suit n'en sais rien a [ __ ] un
bordel là
c'est vrai que ça s'intéressent à tout
le monde se demandait moi je dis la
vérité
non mais on nous a demandé de jouer dans
une publicité faite aux états unis
d'accord qui devait d'abord deux
objectifs 1 nous distinguer l'un de
l'autre et deux et ça c'est le point
important qu'on n'a jamais dit et c'est
la première fois qu'on le nie elle a
[Musique]
alors dit doudou
je suis un truc vous n'avez jamais vu
jamais on n'a jamais parlé à l'isi selon
l'ani voilà vous avez des personnages
des personnages mystérieux oui c'est
vrai que vous interrogez de savoir d'où
vous venez
1 quel est votre origine est en fait ils
ont dit mais on va accentuer et c'est
vrai qu'on s'est vus sur toutes les
affiches là bas et dans tous les réseaux
venant d'une autre planète ah oui oui
non mais c'est vrai ce que je vis
j'espère que mes seins dont vous les
voyez ils ont voulu faire croire que
vous venez d'une autre planète que nous
venions d'un autre monde d'accord et
donc pas et donc ils ont fait une des
expériences ils ont fait oui enfin je
peux paraître un détail mais c'est tout
simplement
c'est ouf ouais et donc ils ont dit
voilà vous venez d'une autre planète
oui c'est vrai je pense que c'est une
question qu'on nous pose régulièrement
et il n'y a pas plus tard que quelques
jours on m'a demandé vider la fnac et là
quelqu'un vient vers moi
le monde dit petit écrit prenez moi
franchement oui
donc vous n'êtes pas d'ici moi je lui ai
répondu de façon assez naturelle
écoutez si si si vous répondez
et si je vous disais qu'on vient
d'ailleurs ouais est ce que vous me
croiriez vous
oui sûrement 1 alors écoutez je ne vous
dirai pas ah ouais c'est aux fins mais
le mac est reparti aller chercher des
dons qu'ils ont voulu faire part aux
techniques venus d'une autre planète
donc ils ont fait des expériences ou ça
vous ne l'avez jamais dit non
complètement tonus jamais
[Rires]
on sais quoi d exister elle pose de
vraies questions on va tirer un moment
donné est ce que moi une expérience une
idée en landes quelque chose alors bien
y'a rien là pas de corps itron schiste
non comme toi d'ailleurs simplement des
expérimentations sur des rayonnements
en fait c'est à dire à berriane ans se
sont longuement de gamme des longueurs
d'onde qui sont plus ou moins pénétrante
en fait
ah oui et donc qui donne qui donne
effectivement en ce moment d'aider on
peut dire des interférences la corvée
des interférences états unis ça qu'ils
ont fait c'est bien entendu et c'est aux
états unis que ça s'est passé c'est ouf
les médias longtemps très longtemps et
vous n'avez jamais regretté ces
expériences non au contre mais vous avez
servi de cobayes en fait aux américains
oui c'est ou balassa pas trop bouger
j'ai sonné des années c'est pas ça à
face à reste stable un certain succès de
malades et ne vivent pas sur la tête de
la mer c'est un truc de ouf
les bodin's moi je te dis ça ils n'ont
pas depuis trente ans ils ont la même
petit on a un truc de ouf c'est ton x
moi des gars quoi c mais c'est vrai
merci en tout cas parce que grichka nous
a répondu à cette question que palm
monde se pose est ce vraiment une
manière très claire